[Musique]
c'est un petit peu un voyage dans le
temps parce que c'est s'aider des
contraintes qui nous sont donnés
aujourd'hui avec les mots d'aujourd'hui
mais transposé dans un siècle
différentes par exemple s'il ya
distanciation sociale dans les autobus
bas comme ils se déplacer à cheval il ya
un cavalier sur deux dans les rangs créé
par exemple voilà c'est cette genre de
de décalage qui est un petit peu petit
peu drôle j'ai posé des questions à mes
lecteurs je leur ai dit si vous étiez
enfermé tout seul dans le château de
versailles
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce qu'il vous
plairait et en fait et en fait j'ai eu
des réponses donc sur instagram il ya ba
moi si j'étais tout seul
j'aimerais avoir la galerie des glaces
pour moi tout seul je ferai une grosse
fête ou alors ce serait des frais des
glissades et ses ébats et face à ce qui
est arrivé des counties louis un moment
voilà je l'envoie faire des glissades
dans la galerie des glaces
[Musique]
j'ai justement fait attention à remettre
un tout petit peu le contexte à chaque
fois avec des dates précises et qu'on
peut retrouver ou des références à des
des allocutions présidentielles et
ministérielles des des conflits sur
l'intérêt du mas de tête concrètement
voilà à chaque fois c'est vraiment
l'histoire de l'année 2020 transposé
dans un monde un peu virtuel à
versailles